there are concerns tonight about the
work environment in the office of vice
president
kamala harris meanwhile the argument
argument over which
party actually favors defunding police
departments
around the country is intensifying
tonight this occurs against the backdrop
of rapidly
escalating crime statistics in many
major cities as we've been covering
white house correspondent peter ducey
takes a look
who defunded the police republicans say
it was democrats we watched crime
continue to spike
as the democrats made that movement just
a few year ago
hear about defunding of the police
democrats say it was
republicans are there any examples of
republican
members of congress saying they want to
defund the police i think most people
would argue that actions are more
important than words wouldn't you say
this map shows that almost all the big
cities that have moved
to defund police departments in recent
years are run
by elected democrats including new york
los angeles and seattle where lance
randle is running for mayor
hoping to boost morale at the local pd
police officers that i've talked to feel
that they're not appreciated
in the federal government at the highest
levels there's a different kind of
trouble brewing
in the vice president's office the road
ahead
will not be easy some on her staff agree
a person with direct knowledge of how
the vp's office operates
tells politico people are thrown under
the bus from the very top there are
short fuses
and it's an abusive environment the
harris portfolio right now includes
some of the most complicated problems
facing the country including
improving vaccination rates immigration
policy
and voting rights i said when
we became a team and got elected that
the vice president was going to be the
last person in the room she didn't
realize that means she gets every
assignment
an official in the vice president's
office points us to this statement from
spokeswoman simone sanders quote we are
not making
rainbows and bunnies all day what i hear
is that people have hard jobs and i'm
like
welcome to the club if murmurs of
unhappiness in the eisenhower executive
office building
have reached the west wing president
biden doesn't seem concerned
about her work product particularly on
addressing root causes of migration
done a great job so far vice president
harris took a lot of
incoming from republicans recently over
that
delayed trip to the border but these new
complaints are coming
from democrats who chose to work for her
in her office and the complaints are
made mostly anonymously which has a
harris spokeswoman
saying the people who come forward like
that are cowards
brett peter dewson live on the north
lawn peter thank you hey sean hannity
here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else